class warfare is a new book from J
Martin Rochester decrying the state of
public education in the United States he
spoke about it recently at left bank
books in st. Louis Missouri for about an
hour I've got to take you back to the
1980s when our two sons Steven and Sean
were in University City Missouri and the
suburbs of st. Louis and a progressive
minded principal had just come to Delmar
Harvard Elementary School and I started
noticing that the newsletters sent home
had fewer and fewer references to words
like rigor and merit and discipline and
more and more references to self-esteem
and inclusion and equity and diversity
and all the bus words we hear these days
and of course my first reaction was well
these are innocent enough who can be
against equity and diversity but I began
to realize that what I was witnessing
was a paradigm shift that is a complete
total utter relaxation and indeed
collapse of standards I first saw this
when the principal announced there would
no longer be in the ability groups in
reading we'd have no more red birds or
blue birds all birds were the beat of
the same feather for so that we didn't
damage anybody's self-esteem
we were told quote there's almost a
direct quote as I recall it all the
research shows that heterogeneous
grouping mixed ability grouping does not
hurt high achieving students end of
quote
and in other words we were told that the
mission of the public schools apparently
was no longer about stretching kids
minds but rather damage control as long
as your kid was not hurt by what was
happening due to some new pedagogical
theory you should be happy this for me
was a real epiphany the next epiphany
though came at in middle school my older
son Steven was an all-county saxophone
player and in the middle school at
University City he was looking forward
to playing in the renowned University
City High School Jazz Band that you had
to audition for and that had produced
remarkable musicians including the chief
accompany as the Wynton Marsalis and
Harry Connick but we were told that the
band was beat the Jazz Band was being
phased out and folded into the marching
band
because quote it was too elitist too
elitist John Brophy
the band director wonderful band
director are left he quit resigned went
to John Burroughs an elite private
school in st. Louis as many of you know
and so the public schools lost was the
private schools again this is a classic
case of the public school shooting
themselves on the feet we moved across
the border into Clayton a neighboring
district and we became house poor in
order to send our kids to a school
district that at least one national
publication had rated the third best
school district in America but much to
our chagrin we began to see similar buzz
words uttered in Clayton and a similar
philosophy to some extent to some extent
beginning to see even into Clayton and
it be clean clear to me that this was
not a youth city problem where a Clayton
problem or a Missouri problem it was a
national problem that is what I call in
the book path pedagogy was everywhere
not only in Clayton and Parkway in
Wilson in virtually every school
district and in the heartland of the
u.s. here in st. Louis but also in my
brother's school district in Montgomery
County Maryland in California where like
the storm systems most of the trends
would start and and it was everywhere
coast to coast I'm talking here about
inventive spelling old language fuzzy
math cooperative learning heterogeneous
well multiple intelligences theory and
full inclusion and what basically in my
judgment has been an attack on gifted
education honors courses on merit-based
grouping based on a very well intention
but nonetheless misplaced obsession with
the bottom with lowest common
denominator education our kind of Lake
Wobegon culture what IDI Hirsch has
called educational populism and what the
former assistant superintendent for
curriculum in my own School District and
Clayton actually called her commitment
to mass excellence and I tried to
explain to her mass excellence is in
oxymoron and this is a brilliant
individual
by the way but it shows you the kinds of
even brilliant minds in K to 12
education that don't always get it now
I'm going to say a lot of potential a
lot of politically incorrect things and
I say a lot of politically uncorrect
things in the book in fact some people
have tried to label me a social
Darwinists the there's a slight problem
with that in 1995 and the 50th
anniversary of the United Nations the
local chapter of the United Nations
Association named me one of 50 st. Louis
UNS who had dedicated their lives to the
peace and justice so i'm not exactly a
poster boy for social Darwinism i
believe very strongly that all kids can
learn they should learn they must learn
as a taxpayer I am committed to
certainly paying tons of resources to
slow learners to kids with disabilities
that's not at issue at issue is whether
the new progressive paradigm works for
any kids the bottom the middle or the
top also an issue is whether schools
that attempt to provide special
opportunities for academic excellence
with a capital e should be vilified or
should be celebrated I think they should
be celebrated the question I have and
then I raised in the book is who's the
elitist is it someone who thinks such
opportunities for academic excellence
should be available only in private
schools or someone like myself who
argues that public schools should stand
for academic excellence no less than
private schools I want to say up front
by the way and and there may even be
some faculty here from Clayton my home
district I say in the book and I'll say
it here Clayton is a world-class school
district and I genuinely mean that they
do wonderful things last year I think
10% of the senior class were National
Merit Scholars which is absolutely
remarkable so in many ways this is a
wonderful School District and I don't
mean to insult anybody but one of the
punch lines of the book in fact maybe
the main punch line of the book is that
even the that questionable things are
going on not just in the usual suspects
we all criticize the inner-city schools
but even in the very finest best most of
scale suburban schools in America and so
the Clayton is one of those let me
elaborate let me try to run through a
few things fairly quickly I will
probably not get through all this that's
fine we'll leave time for Q&A I'm going
to talk about five fads in particular
that I've only hinted that fad number
one is teacher as coach the emphasis
increasingly is on teacher is coach the
guide on the side facilitating
independent and cooperative learning
having children take increasingly
increasing responsibility for their own
learning and this is in contrast to the
traditional direct instruction lecturing
which progressives love the caricature
as sage on the stage Yellin towel chalk
and talk the problem I mean makes for a
great soundbite the problem is what
we're often left with with the
progressive paradigm is what I call the
Socratic method - Socrates - teacher as
cheerleader peer editing which is
usually the blind leading the blind I
think and this was all captured by the
way in a cartoon that I tried to get
into the book and I wasn't able to but
some of you are distributed - beforehand
and the cartoon depicts a child and the
ocean flailing his arms wildly as he's
drowning and there are two lifeguards
will ensure that are watching all this
very calmly and one matter-of-factly
says to the other we're trying to get
him involved in his own rescue well if I
had a dime for every time I heard the
phrase teacher as coach in Clayton or
elsewhere and in the scholarly
literature I'd be I'd be very rich I
wouldn't have to be doing these kinds of
gigs actually um bill Mendelsohn the
social studies coordinator at in Clayton
who I have enormous respect for wrote an
article and the Clayton curriculum
quarterly a couple years ago in which he
confessed that his own colleagues tended
to be somewhat defensive and apologetic
when they admitted that they lectured
that is taught I have nothing against
active learning I in the 1970s I
directed a National Science Foundation
project or an undergraduate
international studies that pioneered
learning by doing
I used simulations I used role-playing
exercises etc etc but I use them as
supplements to teaching not substitutes
I don't know about you but I'm not
paying $50,000 a year for average
teacher salaries for teachers to be
facilitators and to get out of the way
now in my judgment what's not what's
driving this teacher is coach Dean is an
obsession with the bottom there's an
assumption that the entire student body
now suffers from attention deficit
disorder it gets bored easily needs to
be provided fun and games constantly
these days often by a computer that is
becoming a high tech Laura fide
babysitter as one observer said we've
had a generation of absentee parents now
apparently we want a generation of
absentee teachers
all right fad number two is the
heterogeneous mixed ability group
classroom and I referred briefly to this
and the Jazz Band episode I think as the
Jazz Band episode shows pretty clearly
merit and competition are now
four-letter words in many American
schools performance ability formats
based ability grouping is considered
elitist an exemplar of this is a fellow
named Alfie Kohn some of you may be
familiar with them a leading progressive
who if you read Alfie cones work you
would think he was some sort of radical
Marxist on the far extreme fringe of K
to 12 education but in fact cone is a
mainstream thinker reflected in the fact
he was recently a keynote speaker at the
National Council of teachers of English
Convention and national school
superintendents convention tone wrote an
article and I cite him simply as an
exemplar of this problem he wrote an
article in Phi Delta Kappa which is a
very prominent education journal in
March of 1988 entitled only my kid how
privileged parents undermine school
reform in which he attacked honors
courses grades testing and virtually
everything else associated with
standards and called any parents
associate who supported such things
quote Volvo vigilantes now in response I
wrote a piece called what's it all about
Alfie a parent educators response to
Alfie come to my delight captain
published it you can read it in October
1998
Kapaun I was going to quote briefly from
the article but in the interest of time
I'm not going to do it the article some
of the passages appear in the book I
guess I'll quote just one quick passage
it makes about as much sense to put an
intellectually gifted child into the
same math or English or science class
with a lota average student as it would
be to put Cohn where most human beings
on the same basketball court with
Michael Jordan would we expect Michael's
game to improve as a result of playing
against Alfea would we expect Alfie's
game to improve there's a lot more but
in the interest of time I'll move on now
let me say as a district like Clayton as
I say has very strong very strong honors
courses but even I think it's fair to
say even in a district like Clayton
there are relentless pressures
relentless pressures to water down the
standards and ice like clay and their
parental override issues there are all
kinds of other issues that we don't have
time to get into in the Q&A I'm happy to
discuss but I psych Clayton is just one
example of many and Clayton Clayton is
not one of the worst offenders Clayton
to its credit has been trying very hard
against the tide to resist these
pressures what's very odd is that in
higher in public higher education you
have honors colleges increasingly
developed at my university University of
Missouri st. Louis in 1989 we created
something called a Pierre likely Honors
College to serve quote highly talented
and motivated students University of
Michigan has an Honors College Georgia
University of Georgia go down the list
in higher education we've recognized the
need to create special opportunities at
state universities for the best students
who are ready for the most demanding
education in k-12 we're moving exactly
in the opposite direction this makes no
sense whatsoever either higher ed or k12
has it wrong okay I think k12 has it
rolling fad number three is multiple
intelligences theory the main
intellectual rationalization now being
used to justify the attack on ability
grouping is multiple intelligences
theory which is the brainchild of Howard
partner of Howard you know our bird
University who's a very bright fellow
he's a MacArthur Genius award winner his
theory is a very interesting theory that
contains many intriguing insights but
nonetheless has led to some of the most
bizarre silly classroom applications in
the history of American education with
mi theory you can't say the bottom is
driving the curriculum because suddenly
there's no bottom even if you can't
write or read or count or think maybe
you can dribble a basketball or perform
one of the other seven intelligences
that Gardner identifies the theory
basically says or at least a common
interpretation in fairness to Gardner
the common interpretation of a theory
basically says schools should not be
focusing so much on the traditional
intelligences of linguistic verbal
intelligence and mathematical
quantitative logical reasoning
intelligence but should be attempting to
give Co equal treatment to several other
intelligences such as intrapersonal and
interpersonal intelligence which I call
musing and schmoozing and then bodily
kinesthetic intelligence which
essentially equates slam dunking a
basketball with performing open-heart
surgery they all both use the same
tactile talents so now Dennis Rodman is
suddenly a member of the intelligentsia
alongside dr. Michael DeBakey humor is
considered a form of intelligence so the
class clown has also been added in hell
to the list of academically adept people
I jokingly in the book I think maybe the
editor took it out of the book but I
think originally I suggested maybe we
should be inducting the Three Stooges
Tiny Tim and pinky Lee in the National
Honor Society posthumously
more seriously gardner started with
seven intelligences he's now up to at
least nine he's added a couple we may
end up with several dozen before it's
over all of which have to be
accommodated within a 180 day school
year which gives us which aggravates the
problem of a curriculum a mile wide and
an inch deep now again what I think is
driving this is a very well-intentioned
noble notion that we don't want to favor
one kid over another that we don't want
to
damaged any child self-esteem but
nonetheless the effects are just in my
judgment perverse fad number four is the
therapeutic classroom what I call the
Oprah ization of American education this
relates to its intrapersonal and
interpersonal intelligence of course
teachers are increasingly being asked to
play the role of psychologists and
sociologists for which they are
untrained the school day not only is
being taken up with gardeners
smorgasbord of intelligence but
intelligences but also anger management
conflict resolution violence prevention
diversity sensitivity training character
education and about a dozen other things
that used to be the purview mainly of
Family Church and other institutions and
it seems now it's as if that almost all
schools are now considered reform
schools and almost all kids are now
considered wayward kids in need of
reform school training I sent a memo
once to the Clayton school board in
which I said quote most parents are not
spending four hundred thousand dollars a
year for a house in Clayton so that
their kids can get access to the latest
instruction aimed at curbing their
killer instincts or producing a mature
mahatma gandhi's or learning the latest
verses of kumbaya and there's nothing
there's nothing wrong with kumbaya but
but the question is the use of 180 day
school year fad number five is
higher-order thinking and the debasement
of the basics progressives argue that to
the extent schools focused on academics
they should be promoting higher order
skills problem-solving and so forth
giving much less attention to the basics
of teaching grammar punctuation spelling
computation learning the key historical
facts and so forth all of which they
dismiss as rote memorization beneath
teachers to teach or students to learn
and we hear phrases like we're moving
forward with basics not back to basics
well I once told the school board I
don't care if you go forward with basics
back to basics or sideways with basics
but I want the basics talk it is
patently absurd to think that any child
or for that matter a person can do
higher quality
our thinking without a solid foundation
in the basics it's pure atmospherics 10
to 12 folks a lot of them tend to refer
to their charges even preschoolers as a
community of scholars Johnny can't find
the potty but he's a scholar meanwhile
we in higher education are left with
increasingly doing remedial education
and we sort of feel we're surrounded by
graduates of South Park sometimes but
the point is that our education systems
I'm convinced are being turned upside
down
sure let's of course do higher-order
thinking in K to 12 absolutely but we
also need to rededicate ourselves to the
basics again I think what's driving this
is is the bottom if the truth be known
learning basics requires an enormous
amount of discipline and effort
something that I think progressives fear
some kids may not be able or willing to
do so in place of the old maxim no pain
no gain we now have the new one is if it
ain't fun it can't be done very quickly
let's take let's take my let's take one
by one if we have time if not well I'll
try to cut it short and go to cutie Q&A
but let's take math for example fuzzy
math what some people call Ebonics with
an equal sign okay I I don't claim
that's not mine I got that from Tony
Snow or someone else what's fascinating
if you read the literature and you
actually read the fuzzy math inventors
at a one side of their mouth they say
that they're promoting higher-order
thinking problem-solving and so forth
but at the other side of their mouth
they admit and it's in black and white
that that many of these curricula are
targeted at the math folks the kids who
suffer from math anxiety the weakest
students in math and so they're
encouraged to use calculators so as they
so that they don't have to you know they
can avoid the dreariness and and so
forth of learning multiplication tables
and and in doing long division one of
the most amazing stories I tell in the
book is November 18th 1999 The
Washington Post ran an or it was an open
letter in the Washington Post November
18 1999 to Secretary of Education Riley
signed by some of the 200 of the leading
mathematicians in the United States the
chairs of the math departments at
Harvard Yale Stanford Cal Tech
University of Chicago University of
Rochester go down the list for Nobel
laureates I believe urging Secretary of
Education Reilly to repudiate the new
fuzzy math curricula precisely because
they devalue computation skills and
devalued getting the right answer but
this was basically blown off I could
talk about English but I won't because
my good friend Cathy Pierre poor is here
today no actually they have a wonderful
English department in Clayton let me say
a word about social studies they also
have a wonderful social studies
department but they do and I say that in
the book they're not the problem the
problem is the professional development
industry that is getting rich off
nonsense okay the the guy named Gary
Nash at UCLA headed the national history
standards project in 1995 and he was
quoted at the time is saying we want
quote we want to liberate students from
the prison of facts and of quote
now how one can do higher-order thinking
or how you can even remotely be could do
critical thinking about American
democracy without knowing the most
elemental features of about the Republic
and basic facts about American history I
don't I don't quite understand half the
American people do not know they have
two senators much less can name them and
yet we're told we're overdosing people
on facts read the National Geographic
report last December I think it was 87
percent of 18 year olds can identify I
can't find Afghanistan or Iraq on a map
eighty percent can't find Afghanistan 50
percent can't find New York and 11
percent can't find the United States the
National Association of scholars did a
study also this past December in which
they found that the average college
graduate today has about the information
information level as a high school
graduate in 1955 David Broder and July
4th 2000 wrote Opie
losing our civic memory in which you
said even graduates of Harvard and
Amherst were clueless about what the
Gettysburg Address said or anything
about it the late Albert Shanker one of
my heroes the former head of the
American Federation of Teachers just
before he died in 1997 wrote a piece in
the New York Times called knowledge
still camps can you imagine an educator
feeling the need to actually write an
article entitled knowledge still counts
okay let me wrap up within just a minute
or two and then we'll open it up what we
have in my judgment is one gigantic
model right now in the last chapter of
the book I try to offer a way out of the
great American education war I call for
a ceasefire based on really some very
commonsensical not terribly profound
ideas I urge that we and yet even though
these are non profound ideas and common
sensical there's enormous intense debate
and contentiousness and infighting
occurring over this
I urge we strike a balance between the
best of progressive education and the
best of traditionalist education I've
just spent about 30 minutes bashing
progressive education I want to
emphasize something I mentioned in the
book repeatedly progressives have some
incredibly great ideas if only they
would apply them in greater moderation
and not throw the baby out with the
bathwater
that's the gods Fitzgerald once wrote
that the the the test of a first-rate
mind is to be able to hold two competing
ideas in your mind at once and still
function well let's try it for a minute
let's let's dedicate ourselves to
promoting both creativity and rigor
higher-order thinking
and memorization and basic skills active
learning and direct instruction
targeting resources at both slow
learners and fast learners these are not
mutually exclusive ideas and I go on to
say in conclusion I go on to say that if
schools are not going to respond to this
call for balance and to respond to the
concerns the traditionalists have read
have raised and I think we need to open
the game up to choice let me stress I'm
a public school person I'm a product of
the public schools my kids went to
public schools I never thought of
sending my kids even remotely
private schools I believe in the public
schools but if they're not going to
respond then I think we do have to give
parents some some options progressives
love to talk about empowering children
well maybe we need to empower adults
parents to choose the option they think
best if a parent wants diagramming of
sentences they should be able to get it
without having to hire outside tutors if
they want their kids to learn math facts
more than they're learning they
shouldn't have to hire some kind of
Kumaon math instructor progressives talk
a good game about diversity and
accommodating diverse learning styles
but in my judgment it's of one
one-size-fits-all constructivist
paradigm the same people who tell
children there are no right or wrong
answers when it comes to parents claim a
monopoly of wisdom and not only was
parents but traditionalists educators or
progressives claim a monopoly of wisdom
so I call for a peaceful more productive
dialogue that's why I wrote the book and
I'll stop there and be happy to take
your questions thank you
anyone have a question a comment a
disagreement hopefully yes now do we
need to I think the mic has to come
around did you want to ask a question is
that right if you could just wait one
moment
I'm in a master's program right now for
teaching I've never taught before but
and now we entered into into a master's
program and I'm interested to know what
you would say to all of my professors
who are going to teach me to teach if
you could what I would say is really my
final salvo at the end which is please
I'd make a plea to please be more
sensitive to alternative diverse points
of view that are not always taught in
the schools of Education someone like
Edie Hirsch who wrote cultural literacy
in the schools we need someone like Tom
Lovelace the director of the brown
center of educational policy at the
Brookings Institution Chester Finn
Sandra Stawski who wrote losing our
language a wonderful book I would urge
that your professors not only assigned
sizer and Meir and Gardner and alfie
kohn particularly we hope they want to
sign out become but that's all right but
those others are giant figures in
education who certainly deserve to be
heard but so do Hirsch and Lovelace and
ravaged Diane Ravich so I call for
diversity that's what I would hope would
happen I think there's one there and
then
yes I would just to say I've been
teaching for 32 years in university city
school system and I believe students
just from talking to them want to be
intellectually engaged unfortunately
there are many teachers that are
teaching now that don't know the first
thing about how to plan lessons and if
you want a paraphrase in Clinton
administration it's the teachers stupid
and if we don't have bright creative
teachers it doesn't matter what you say
our society does not value them we don't
put the resources into training them a
1/3 of all teachers leave after 5 years
because they're so frustrated many of
the brightest ones what do you have to
say about that how could we encourage
our society as a whole to really value
teaching
that's a great question first of all my
book is not against teachers in fact my
book is dedicated to quote those
remarkable brilliant teachers , not
facilitators my children learn from I
teachers enormous Lee what I would say
an answer your question is that part of
the reason why teachers leave the
profession and don't even begin to enter
the profession certainly has to do with
salary you're absolutely right we have
to improve salaries but another reason
is discipline the fact that
administrators do not back teachers up
with discipline the fact that we know
teach teach in my judgment don't treat
teachers as professionally as we should
I think we frankly we should have a
merit pay system if you're a superstar
teacher as in higher education you
should be entitled to major major salary
increases beyond the norm and if you're
dead wood you should be fired this is
very hard to do today a lot of young
very talented young people who would
like to go into teaching quite frankly
they don't they don't they don't see the
way how it's a profession so I take your
point
teaching is absolutely critical it's one
of the most important jobs in the
profession and frankly what you do is
more important than what I do for a
living at the heart at higher education
somebody else had her
I am speaking as a parent I'm a mom and
I'm a mom who's been there at field
trips which in the city schools in the
magnet schools we sometimes have six a
month in one classroom field trips
parties all that kind of stuff I'm there
at the school all the time and the
things that I see are pretty much what
you've described I mean that that I have
to agree with a hundred percent of it
another thing that I've noticed though
and I have the question is the kids the
kids don't have fun anymore everything
is a lesson the the field trips are a
lesson they don't have there one field
trip of a year that's fun
they're their recesses have been cut
down to about twenty minutes a day and
that's it 20 minutes out of each day of
seven hour period for children and then
they're they're not allowed to speak at
lunch they get in trouble if they talk
at lunch they're not allowed to be
children anymore at school it is what I
witness in the name of trying to get
accreditation or and this is two
different school systems this is the
magnet schools here in the city and also
a rural school that you know was out in
the country and supposed to be very good
and both situations I experienced the
same thing well I think first of all
schools very enormous Lee in this
respect Clayton for example takes great
pride in having an open campus and
promoting for better or worse and
there's an upside to downside student
freedom and so my guess is and Clayton
there may be a somewhat different view
of things but I'll be honest with you
one thing that constantly puzzles me
when I read the New York Times or other
reports about backpacks getting too big
and kids getting too stressed and too
much homework maybe cuz I'm just old
school I guess I don't quite get it I
know what I had to do as a as a student
for example I tell the story in the book
I it was as a matter of routine I walked
about six seven blocks to a bus I don't
a bus went about seven miles got off a
bus got on another bus it took me an
hour to get the Baltimore City College
High School okay each way nobody warned
about it I mean is what you did was the
best school in town that's what you did
today it'd be child abuse illiteracy
litigation so much time consumed and
having to be in the classroom and then
plus all the the field trips and the the
other stuff that interfere well again
this this race is the issue of it what
can you cram into a seven hour a day 180
day school year I think we're trying to
do too much I think we're asking
teachers to do too much I don't know
there's someone else who has a question
or a comment I think about AP classes I
think in your book I'm not sure what
page it's on I've went down the row but
you talked about the fact that so many
kids want to get into AP classes some
that are not academically that able and
how it waters down the AP classes and I
have a little different take on that and
I don't know if you're familiar with a
book by Jay Matthews I think he's a
professor I mean I think he's on the
staff of the Washington Post he wrote
one called class struggle a few years
back and his I think basic thesis was
that the best high schools and he just
wrote about high schools not about K
through 12 the best high schools have a
lot of AP classes and AP students in
them they encourage all kids to want to
to take AP classes but also he really
pushes that anyone who takes an AP class
really ought to take the exam because
they'll get more out of the class if
they know they're preparing for the exam
and I'm wondering what you think about
that idea of allowing anyone who really
wants to take a challenging course to do
so but not watering down the course and
pushing those kids to take the AP exam
well first of all I exchanged a lot of
emails with J Mathews we have a friendly
disagreement over this issue by the way
he called my book a great read I'm happy
to say so thanks thanks for the plug for
bringing up J Matthews he's a I respect
him a lot and
you're right he has a very different
take on this but I'll give you my take
and it's it's what you suggested and
that is this that I don't understand how
logically something can be billed as the
ultimate capstone academic challenge
that a k-12 system has to offer which AP
is and yet is doable by every last kid
in the building I mean I'm sorry I don't
understand again its mass excellence I
don't understand the concept now let me
say this I respect your point and in
fact I would agree with you that
certainly we should be willing to
probably take a broader view then we
have certainly when I went to school of
giving kids a chance but but I don't
think you just get any kid a chance who
wants to be in there because think about
it what that means is what if you know
Johnny wants to be an AP because his
girlfriend Shirley's there now Johnny's
now an AP and of course the teacher has
to call on Johnny every few minutes or
whatever you know every few days it's a
waste of time for the other students in
the class it really does in my judgment
undermines the academic integrity of the
program but I do take your coin yeah
Marty is a good friend and colleague and
we my name is Dennis Lubich I've been in
education since 1965 20 years as a
teacher and another 15 or so in the
professional development world that's
been criticized pretty sharply in the
book and some of it deserved without
without in it without any question but I
have a couple of sort of related
questions I that I think are important
and one is the book focuses a lot on
progressive education versus traditional
education you know in a sort of a plea
for a ceasefire at the end of the book
and I guess one part of this is is this
really the price it's an important issue
but is it the primary issue and I think
mrs. Shapiro teacher who asked that
question before and isn't the issue
really having people of academic
substance who care for kids entering the
profession and that the pedagogy is kind
of second
to the quality of the people entering
entering the profession and a related a
related point which I found intriguing
the book is agree I should preface this
it's a great read and I applaud you for
stimulating debate we need to debate
education issues more than we more than
we do but a related question relates to
what I think is a problem in the book
from my point of view and the the the
names really don't matter because I know
the c-span is filming this and this is
going to go to a national audience not
just to a local audience but I noticed
that you used what I think of as very
gifted administrative leaders one from a
private school one from a public school
and that you also used very you admitted
this very gifted teachers one was an
English teacher one was a history
teacher as examples of what's wrong and
I guess the question is can you use the
best to prove to prove the worst I mean
the other was you were using very gifted
people showing what's wrong with
American education isn't that what we
should be applauding you know having
administrators and teachers of that kind
of caliber that you use are cited as a
problem so these are kind of related to
the kind of quality of people that we
have working in our schools with with
our kids so well first of all I had
about 30 minutes to give my take and
even in 300 pages frankly I don't think
you can truly capture the complexity of
these issues we're talking about a lot
of pieces of the puzzle James Coleman in
1966 still had I think the definitive
study that said there's a limit to what
schools can do in the absence of parents
and strong home family support systems
where kids are forced encouraged to read
books to study to do homework there's a
limit to what any school in America can
do so parents are part of the problem
teachers are part of the problem in
terms of teachers we need we need higher
standards for teachers I mentioned in
Clayton and elsewhere there's some
brilliant teachers
and they're not the problem but there
the way we credential teachers these
days frankly is very very questionable I
think there's just a lot of people who
don't belong anywhere near a classroom
who are teaching we need higher
standards for teachers and I still think
it comes down to a commitment to
standards in the classroom and this is
where the AP question comes in what do
we consider standards are we committed
to the very highest academic integrity
and standards and I think that is
fundamental now let me get to your the
the second question about how the fact
that I perhaps unfairly seem to
criticize some of the some of the most
brilliant minds and education Howard
Gardner and some other people well again
my point is that it's easy to criticize
the idiots it's easy to criticize you
know inner-city schools that's been done
okay
I always trying to show that that even
in that the problem is systemic and
endemic in education generally that even
in the best places among the best minds
you can see some in my judgment fuzzy
thinking in chapter 2 of the book I talk
about the Stockholm Syndrome in Reverse
where you know in Stockholm Syndrome is
where terrorist captives tend to start
taking on the views of their captors
well in education this seems the more
you're around children the more you
start thinking like children sometimes
and I'm talking about some brilliant
people some of these ideas that I that I
write about that I personally witnessed
and so forth I think are ridiculous and
yet some of them are coming from the
very best minds so I don't know if that
adequately answers your question
anyone else as was discussed earlier the
superintendent of the st. Louis Public
Schools resigned to announce his
resignation yesterday and I wondered if
you were superintendent of the st. Louis
Public Schools what you would do and
related with 42,000 students most of
whom are below grade level and related
to that is how could you make sure what
would you do to make sure that all
children were reading on or above grade
level by third grade
well it's a great question it's easy for
me to stand up here and tell you what I
would do if I were the superintendent of
st. Louis City Schools this is an
enormous challenge I don't come back to
the Coleman report that there's a limit
to what even those teachers can do and
that superintendent can do in the
absence of very solid home support
systems but nonetheless even there's a
limit we have to try and in fact it's
absolutely critical absolutely critical
to reach these kids and to somehow find
a way to get through now regard to
reading for example there's no question
there's no question hole language
doesn't work with with many of those
students not all the students with main
you know students they need much more
systemic structured disciplined explicit
but you want to call it phonics call it
phonics and I'm not talking about all
those students in the inner city one
thing I really object to and I say this
in the book is I really object the
stereotyping and racial profiling that
goes on too much but but clearly there's
no question that many of the kids in
inner-city schools whether they're black
or white come from homes which for
various reasons do not you know they
don't value reading or the parents are
too busy or too poor and there's some
very legitimate reasons sometimes and so
these are the problems have to deal with
now so one is one quick answer your
question I think you need to change the
reading programs and a lot of these
schools I think okay a second is they do
have some excellent schools in the city
like Metro and some others and I think
they did it they need to do more of a
job of trying to target highly talented
kids to some again very high-powered
programs where more than are currently
being served I think that they need to
listen to IDI Hirsch IDI Hirsch is a guy
who you know a professor at University
of Virginia who in 1988 would wrote a
book called cultural literacy in which
he said that all kids rich poor black
white but particularly poor kids needed
to get exposure to basic solid factual
historical information who was Julius
Ebert Caesar who was Cleopatra whatever
Lincoln George Washington Jefferson
because at particular inner-city kids
because of
don't get it in school they're not going
to get it the rich kids will get it one
way or another he Hirsch was accused of
being a right-winger Eurocentric every
name in the book imaginable he started
something called the core knowledge
foundation and it's been very successful
in a number of any inner-city schools I
don't know the extent to which the city
of st. Louis uses it if they don't they
should it's not a panacea the problems
are so challenging but but there are
some of those things that that could
happen I know that doesn't adequately
answer your question it's a it's a huge
challenge but some of those are some of
the things someone else well I think
there's some why is it that a country
like Costa Rica which has one of the
highest literacy rates in the world
can manage to make literacy happen as
poor as they are and as as as limited as
their resources are whereas a country
like the United States with virtually
unlimited resources can't find a way to
obtain the same level of literacy well
actually technically if you look at the
World Bank Atlas or you look at similar
kinds of so-called authoritative sources
of data believe it or not it says that
the United States has 99% literacy just
like Costa Rica now I don't know enough
about Costa Rica to say whether that
figure is more valid in their case than
our case or not I it's a good question I
honestly don't have a good answer to
your question other than to repeat
something I said earlier which is I
think in my judgment in English language
arts I think we're doing one of the
worst jobs and it don't say Clayton I'm
just talking generally in the United
States because I think there's not
enough attention to systematic grammar
and punctuation and and mechanics and so
forth for example in 1996 the National
Council of teachers of English in 1996
produced their so-called national
English standards which pushed invented
spelling PowerPoint all kinds of things
virtually nothing
about the use of language the clear
tight accurate use of standard English
conventions New York Times called the
National Council of teachers of English
national standards pedagogical molasses
I think the Department of Education
pulled the funding on it and yet the
National Council of teachers of English
I know is very respected among English
teachers and I'll just be very honest
with you I don't know why I don't know
why why do the teachers unions tolerate
mediocrity and in some cases worse
because unless you commit rape on the
church steps at high noon you can't be
fired and in some states can you answer
the question without using the word
tenure well well of course I have 10
years
we're fighting post-tenure review at the
four full professors at the university
but anyway I don't want to turn this
into a Union bashing session unions are
part of the problem now we all know why
unions exist we all know the good things
they do they will protect teachers who
often do need protection whether for
academic freedom or whatever they do
some very important good things but
there's no question that they protect
Deadwood there's absolutely no question
about it I I would like to see maybe
it's not possible I would like to see in
k-12 education a merit-based system as I
indicated before that's more similar to
higher education higher education at my
university or most universities when
there is money available for raises
which these days is rare not everybody
gets the same percentage increase in
salary if you've just written two books
one year you get a higher increase than
the person who's been mowing his lawn
most of the year okay in k-12 education
everybody gets the same basically I mean
according there's a system of steps and
so for not everybody gets the same exact
salary but it's it's all unionized I
really genuinely respect teachers
much I think we need to start treating
them like the professionals they are I
want superstar teachers to be paid
better much better than they now are
there are other teachers who don't
deserve to be in the classroom I think
this gentleman over here him I guess I'm
speaking as a product of one of those
really great public schools LeDoux high
school I'm very thankful for the
education I got there and I'm still
working on being a product of the public
schools at the University of Illinois
and I think that one of the problems
that I've seen with what you've said so
far is the definition of excellence I
think your definition is very misleading
and is putting pressures on my peers and
those a few years younger than me that
we don't need and don't help us I think
that the emphasis on AP coursework it
isn't necessary I think it pushes people
to go past the basics and cease learning
the basics in high school as
insufficient and it makes people feel
like there's something wrong with them
now I'm saying this from the perspective
of someone who took a lot of AP courses
and I did well and I you know I get to
college and they're telling me that I've
already completed three semesters of my
college education but one of the other
things I did in high school I spent some
time tutoring other students who weren't
doing so well and some of the students
who I tutored in my senior year of high
school were sophomores juniors and we'd
start working on things like calculus
and they wouldn't know how to multiply
fractions and wait what what's happening
there why are they taking a course
that's pushing them ahead why are they
trying to achieve this standard of
excellence before they've mastered the
basics so I think it's this push for so
called excellence that is undermining
student's ability to achieve excellence
in the end and also that puts enormous
psychological pressure on people to have
these high test scores and to have
finished almost half of their college
education before they even go to college
I think that's a huge problem
and I think we need to come up with a
definition of excellence that means
getting a good high school education in
four years of high school and then we
make some very good points then many of
which by the way I agree with but let me
ask you this do you think mass
excellence makes any sense would you say
mass excellence is a meaningful concept
no I don't think it is but I also think
that it's a very I think it's a dirty
form of upper class warfare when a kid
like me gets the education I got and
poor kids in the inner cities don't
learn basic math skills and the school
that I go to gets twice the funding they
do
I think that's dirty and I think it's
wrong I think you need to probably try
to eliminate look I I respect that and
in fact I welcome a diverse set of views
which I in fact hope would be more of in
more of this conversation in education I
respect very much what you're saying I
agree with part of what you're saying
about AP as far as the latter term I
mean we have a capitalist system now if
you don't want capitalism that you're
free to take that point of view I
respect that but you know you're what
you're talking about of course is not a
capitalist system so you need to decide
in your own mind whether you want a
capitalist system or not and you I'm not
saying which is better you all everybody
in this room really has to make that
determination let me just say something
else about the whole business of making
demands on people you know I mentioned
we have an Honors College at the
University of Missouri st. Louis you
asked any professor at the University of
Missouri st. Louis or any professor in
America if they teach an honors course
and they teach an honors course whether
they make the same demands on all
students it's well understood that in an
honors class you can you can make far
more demands intellectual challenges on
students then you can have them well
read more books write longer papers and
you can in a regular class it just can't
be done if you put everybody in the same
class you are watering down the
curriculum and there is absolutely no
question about it and that's where I'm
coming from I believe all kids I said
before all kids can learn must learn
should learn by
the way I'm against the old-style
tracking that I had at Barbara City
College High School where it was to
exclusivist one set of kids went one way
never saw the other kids I'm not
advocating it I'm advocating course by
course subject by subject if you've got
a bunch of math whiz it's ready to soar
put them together they may not be
English whizzes maybe they'll be in the
regular English class with everybody
else if you've got some gifted writers
put them together if you have some
gifted artists put them together what
we're doing is put them all we're
putting them all together in this one
huge heterogeneous classroom and we're
pretending we now use the term
individualizing instruction Reverend
everybody doing drawing dancing writing
everything else across the curriculum
it's ridiculous and that's where I'm
coming from this lady I'm sorry if sorry
see I'm speaking as a former public
school teacher of 14 years and right now
for the last 13 years I've been in a
teacher education in Washington
University I'm professor in that part of
our program
and kind of to add to the complexity of
the problem as you refer to it I wonder
how many people are aware of in terms of
teacher preparation where do those
directions come from well they come from
the department of elementary and
secondary education in the state of
Missouri and that's that is a one way
pipeline okay and most recently in 1997
the Department of elementary and
secondary education as an example water
down the requirements to become a
science teacher in this state to the
point where you had to have eight hours
eight semester hours of biology and you
could be a biology teacher eight
semester hours of chemistry and you
could be a chemistry teacher and in high
school now that's absurd and what
happened at an institution like ours is
people stopped becoming certified as
science teachers because it was
ridiculous and we couldn't support that
as an institution
most recently the latest trend from the
Department of elementary and secondary
education is for a collet for colleges
of education for departments of
Education statewide to find faster ways
to certify people okay most recently
they send a statement to us telling us
that if someone was working as a
teacher's aide in in a school okay and
wanted to become a certified teacher we
could not ask them to do any kind of
student teaching within our program we
had to accept their work as a teacher
aid as evidence of that okay one last
thing as you know reflection of this I
think it was last spring there was a
huge article in the Post Dispatch about
how the st. Louis City public school
district had hired 49 Teach for America
people now I'm not against Teach for
America but they you know they talked
about how they wined and dined these new
teachers so on so forth way more than
they've done with other people who go
there as new teachers and I consistently
hear this even at my own University
where people say well I'd like to go do
Teach for America because I'd like to
teach for a few years before I decide
what I want to do well okay teachers I
want to say that you know we're not in
control of in many ways how we prepare
them that comes down from on high well I
also mentioned the parents but let me
just respond first of all you're at
Washington University is that right yeah
well obviously you know Wash U has a
very rigorous respected program not all
ed schools in America are that way I
know why shoes is now let me say a
couple things first of all you're right
that and here's me here my political
science hat comes on there's a lot of
politics involved here when you talk
about the Department of elementary and
secondary education in Missouri or
anywhere else what has to happen is
parents and and others have to mobilize
including school districts to put
pressure on legislators to put pressure
on the bureaucracy to change the rolls I
mean it's called politics let me just
say one word though about alternative
certification I take your point that
that it can it can it end up in disaster
and very untrained teachers but let me
just give you one quick anecdote and
case study that suggests maybe we need a
little more flexible accreditation
requirements I had a student last summer
in my American politics class brilliant
young lady had a bachelor's degree from
Truman State University
which is a respected University
certainly in Missouri and a master's
degree in English and a bachelor's
degree and was dedicated wanted to teach
high school English incredibly
intellectual master's degree in English
enormous Lee subsidy well-trained
well-read she called me horror stories
what she had to go through I won't name
the School of Education but she in fact
she had to take my course now now she
said she liked it of course that was
before I graded her but but but the
point is why did she have to take intro
to American politics to teach high
school English and she probably had to
take some kind of lab science and some
kind of public speaking and who knows
what does this was this young lady
desperately wanted to get in the class
I'd get out for a minute I'd have my kid
learn from her in a minute and that's
happening all over the country just the
courses you outlined right there those
are all designated by the Department of
elementary and secondary well we all
need to change that I think yeah I guess
I want to make that point because it's
so easy to say the schools and images of
tenured teachers who couldn't you know
teach their way over a paper bag come to
mind and it's a lot more complex than
that and as taxpayers and voters sooner
or later we have to take responsibility
to change how you know power is
organized in the educational system and
it's not organized at the school level
not very well organized it's organized
at the state well not even federal level
so much as the state and it's not enough
to point the finger and say who's not
doing a good job when we're ignorant of
how those decisions are made and stay
out of house decisions I take your point
and and I did say it's an incredibly
complex problem anyone else I'm sorry if
someone's been waiting I don't know J
Martin Rochester is author of class
warfare besieged schools bewildered
parents betrayed kids and the attack on
excellence it's published by encounter
books on the web at encounter books calm